well this is the most surreal Pink
Panther sequel I've ever seen I mean I
know they're taking some liberties with
the spin-off but there is no connection
to the Blake Edwards original at all
I was very dismissed dismiss wait I got
an opening I'm like what are these like
I gotta kill it
I'm just gonna do it just let me do it
yes what was your brilliant opening I
remember yeah I was so good it didn't
end with it didn't end with I was
dismissed not now just does that mean
it's okay a special time in a boy's life
where he thinks he's gonna see a sequel
to Pink Panther every boy goes through
this and when he doesn't see that
instead he sees a pretty good Marvel
movie but not a Pink Panther sequel
he's dismissed he's dismissed it as not
a Pink Panther sequel you're the reason
Michael B Jordan wanted to kill that is
on you like here is the example right
fucking colonizer and you are the white
boy next oh my god oh I know watching
this movie and I'm like who's the first
white boy then chief al is just like Oh
Bucky it's taut like I heard everyone
laughing I'm just like I'm not I live
like that was it do we give away the
thing after the end credits does it
matter like now that you said that I
mean well you kind of even work
particularly well knows that nobody at
the end no that's at the end of Civil
War of it ah master it lets that you
just talk about the damn movie this is a
good movie I love this movie I thought
it was great I I don't love it there's
there's two things I love it there's two
things I solidly loved I loved the world
the world is I feel like Marvel is just
ripping the two things I love this movie
Marvel feel like they're finally really
getting down and exploring one is the
world because they're doing that a lot
they're creating beats mats a second is
socio-political commentary every single
Marvel movie just a wash now what a few
times I'm like oh hey hey know that
you're actually talking about share do
know and the second is the villain I
feel like between and Michael Keaton uh
like we got to we got really great
Marvel velu villa and that we got two
really good villains in this movie alone
he's not he's the he's one of the
Tolkien white guys and him and Martin
Freeman it like Andy Serkis is not
intimidating but he's definitely like a
scene stealer like yeah he says he's the
funny villain and he says I'm just
fuckin crazy
I'm crazy I really have one boy just
won't go he's just like maybe there's
some car chase in the movies like what
you fucking funeral push them dog at
beautycon agreement Bilbo meet up I
guess long to say you know pop quiz
what's in my pocket but no even Michael
Michael B Jordan Isaac finally he's in a
good Marvel movie man like I was just
the minute I didn't need Redemption the
people behind I don't know what that is
Vaughn I guess but I did it's owned by
said and then oh he was going to be the
main villain when I saw him and but I
was immediately like who's this dude
like I just want to know this guy's
story and you gonna fit at the British
Museum like his first yeah who is this
guy I want to see you more in this movie
yeah and I am the more and more his role
cap bigger and bigger I just got more
and more excited cuz I'm just like oh my
god love this is doing it's like when
you're at kind of a double party and you
find the one interesting person you're
just like I need to talk to you yeah but
yeah this was like he just the money was
good so far but it's like this yeah
it's a slow build so it's like one of
those parties it's just getting started
you don't know everybody it's a slow
build and then he just shows up and I'm
just like you we need an order you like
instantly it's like hey then everything
else in this movie I like I can't think
of anything I dislike I can't take it
back
some of the effects are like Wonder
Woman bad you know I saw this CGI isn't
great yeah I say about 1/3 of it is
pretty bad but 2/3 of it with the
environments especially are just
gorgeous and the cool little gadgets and
everything but yeah whenever play
particularly when Black Panther needs to
be running or jumping or anything like
that like it wants the early
two-thousands ban let's play too bad
half the time but everything else about
so visually is so stunning and you know
and I like the characters and everything
but it didn't bother me it's sold it's
badness with enough style that I think
that's my thoughts there's so much style
that I'm just like oh whatever
it's like Wonder Woman I mean it doesn't
that are awful but everything else is
good I don't care really effects in the
end are really awful I thought the
effects are all right for about the
first half of that movie really that
Island when she jumps off and the oh
well your catches through it oh I'm
sorry
I think I will dismiss your comment you
should there's no pink Panther's did you
not smear the explanation what it is I
can't believe that was what you were
just like oh my god take all the kids
know and lumping Panther overall I mean
so this is what the live-action Lion
King looks like there is no goddamn
live-action Lion King they're all gonna
be animated again it's a laughing that's
the Lion King I digress um Forest
Whitaker makes it Yankee it's turning
into a king like but here's the thing
that's all Joseph Campbell shit like
that happens and all sorts of stories
and myths and stuff that's following out
of a play
book but it I just I don't know I'm
impressed that now we finally have a
Disney movie set in Africa with like 90%
black people in it yeah good for them
like you would have thought Lion King
would have done that we're gonna set our
first animated film in Africa well there
will be no actual drawn black people
it's all animals okay oh and the cast is
gonna be like mostly white we shall we
got James Earl Jones I was thinking to
myself with this movie you know I'm
watching it and I'm liking it fine but
I'm saying to myself like that this is
not kind of your typical Marvel movie
and I was trying to think like no they
actually seriously yeah there is not
much humor in this like very very little
I was overly well and I was trying to
yeah I like zombies but I'm just like
I'm kind of at the point where like
there were so many dramatic moments in
this I'm like if they botched this with
a lame joke and really I think they only
did it like once where like you had kind
of a dramatic moment and they had a joke
and I'm like okay you earned it like
there aren't a lot of scenes like you
know the biggest recent offender and I
love that movie cuz I went into it just
expecting it to be kind of trashy a
tease both or three but like that one
just had every serious moment it's like
and funny line like insert no you can't
feel for too long we need to have a
funny joke this one that's like no you
can feel we're going to make you feel
people are gonna talk about things
they're going to deal with life issues
we're gonna talk about everything under
the Sun then they do that in other
Marvel films too but you're right they
sued they rely more and more on the
humor recently it's kinda nice to get
something dramatic back buddy but but
here's the day to talk about important
things occasion like guardians of the
galaxy I thought a the whole father
something that was good
yeah actually that's pretty serious and
it's a good movie that's still though
like you go into that though like
thinking comedy yeah that's a talking
raccoon and it's like I went into this
not knowing what to expect but I came
out of it going like wow that was a
fucking like that was a Greek tragedy I
just saw like I was
like that like the villain with let's
talk about the villain for a second
probably my favorite part honestly you
don't I liked about the villain um and
this is the key to good villains but
nobody tells it quite right
like they're always like I'm just evil
that's my thing I mean like a really
good villain thinks he's the hero in the
story and is too warped to realize these
knocks yeah I'll argue the Marvel
villains it's funny the problems with
this movie that I do have our very minor
but it's like I haven't cuz I seen this
so many times in other Marvel movies and
I still say this one does not do a lot
with the other Marvel movies do but its
weaknesses does come from the fact that
it's kind of doing my movies do and one
of them is see that's what I see that
they always see why do you see this as a
bad thing I'm clearly doing what's right
I'm doing it we the audience know it's
wrong but with him he comes from such a
background I'm like that's the problem
with the Marvel villains oh it's like
they can say that but I said they don't
do it right like you just always I can't
but really you're just evil like it's it
this is the first guy where when he
makes that point like what I think I'm
doing the right thing and I kinda had to
sit there for it was like you know he's
got kind of a point like the right thing
to him is legit revenge like yo fuck
these guys fuck everything and it's like
there's a one part where it's like what
like to this and it's like no I know it
I get it
everything made sense and the way they a
fleshed-out in his background with the
visions he saw like that a man has
performed she was oh his performance was
a yeah always
he stole he stole the show he really you
know everybody's great in this movie but
I think when people are gonna talk about
this movie like years to come they're
gonna go like oh Michael Jordan yeah an
Andy Serkis because I'm crazy but he has
this scene with a Vision Quest they go
on and then Black Panthers case you know
he sees his Dan detoxes Dan
and in was it warmonger no wait kill
kill mana be confusing it with Iron Man
whatever I don't know he they didn't
call him it much it was like some
throwaway line he has a vision with his
dad too and I thought oh maybe this is
gonna go like I don't know darker as
dad's you're like no I'll get revenge
and instead it played out like this
super serious really sad scene and I'm
like this is some real drama tucked in
the middle of a Marvel but like they
really went for it anyway back and forth
between what he is now what he was yeah
yeah I'm like this is crazy good like I
would not have expected this from you
have a movie like everything around him
no not a single joke to wreck that scene
either this worth or threaten you como
ki would have been Pratt falling in the
back and she that would have been
amazing the move is a Vision Quest
another thing like little-to-no Marvel
cameo now either which again is very
welcomed but yet no buts please but some
of the things missing that okay so some
things they put in that I think as we
see a lot of these Marvel movies you can
see it coming they're not bad but it's
like there's a guy at the end he's like
will you help us no I will not interfere
we have what happens there's when
they're talking to us that was the Lord
of the Rings moment when they get like
you know this guy it's like You Know Who
I am you know yes you are you're an FBI
agent you used to be a pilot guess what
he's gonna do you know there's a whole
bunch of sins like that where they're it
could have been working more organically
but it's not too distracting I feel like
just because I've seen these movies so
many times I'm catching on to a morphic
crowd-pleaser mo yeah it's like I
recognize these but it's not it's not
distractingly bad but this game to a
point or even in a wine or thing I
didn't mind actually at all no no I just
took it as like cuz he's never flown
that thing remember I just took it as
well these people are so advanced they
made this thing so witty proof of like I
could fly
for American right the the the the
general talking to ioves another general
or whatever she's like you know my ching
my love
we must blah blah blah that is never
referenced again until the very end they
have no chemistry no romance whatever
but I get why because it's too you know
make it for where you know that the
battle you gotta end this battle and
stuff and they have this exchange and
like okay I got that but I immediately
know why they put that in is to set up a
scene later you're not actually doing it
so they have like this romantic
chemistry thing is that it's but yeah it
doesn't bother me that bad but it's like
these are the things that come with the
genre to me that's like the same people
company but where did you forget all
these barrels of petroleum too close to
them this is just the comic books you're
like yeah disbelieve like that that
doesn't bother me at all
but but okay here doesn't much it bother
me except that here's a nice thing to
though that that did legit bother me a
little bit like I said the rest of the
movie is good enough is charming enough
but I'm like man I would have loved this
movie if Black Panther had more black
panther there is not much black panther
in this well that's what that's what I
thought the weird bait and switch of the
movie was I was just like in fact he's
actually like out okay was twenty thirty
minutes of the movie like now they've
been the kind of the character they
generally pull the Silence of the Lambs
where like there's that weird sex in the
movie where for 15 minutes you lose your
primary yeah there's much once but I
mean but kept a lot of the side
characters here but it but you you get
an action scene in the beginning that
shot entirely in the dark like black and
you got a black guy wearing a black suit
in the entirely black background so you
don't see that much you have a really
cool kick-ass action scene without the
car and the bridge yeah but you know
what and then arch you doesn't show up
again until the yeah you know it
I haven't I have no fucks to give
because that car chase was worth the
price of admission alone that car chase
through boson South Korea or whatever
that was freakin amazing
I rode the high off that through the
rest of the movie like just fine
but but is one of those things were
again it's kind of
that it it is a different kind of Marvel
movie and it my frenching I'm just like
no it's less jokes this fire honestly
this felt like what a DC movie kind of
wants to be but can't quite like this is
closer to like him then maybe this is
what I like it cuz in the in the Marvel
scheme of things I feel like this is
closer to them wanting to be like DC in
the same way that Wonder Woman in some
ways felt like maybe that was trying to
be a little more Marvel like we're
seeing a bait-and-switch here because I
think both sides have gotten a little
stale so it's like what are you doing
over there let's let's see if we can
incorporate some well and one I think
the funny thing is I think in both cases
the DC movie was made better for it the
Marvel movie here I think is made better
for it
well yeah it's nice to get some a little
different and I was trying to think
about like you know I I feel like
whenever you come out of a Marvel movie
you're immediately trying to rank it
will wear with this ring wear with this
and this one or or which one is this one
light this is like a mix between blank
and blank and is its own thing yeah I
think of what would was it the closest
okay no no the closest I could think of
maybe Winter Soldier closest but even
Winter Soldier had more comedy and to
kind of break it up a little bit it's
like this one really kind of seemed like
in its own universe and sort of its own
style but to deal with great moral
choices to the other Marvel movies in
some a in Civil War in Winter Soldier
particularly the Captain America ones I
think they really really do that's yeah
you named the two like what those count
but Bob sang even then there's still
like I think of all the other ones that
I'm like somehow seems removed and again
I think it is sort of the lack of humor
which again I I didn't mean what I could
used a little bit more you know here's
the thing because like thank God okay no
here's the thing those movie I thought
it was refreshing
no the Civil War and Winter Soldier are
both sequels and kept America it is not
that great a movie yeah it's ok but but
it's not anything super heavy super drag
maybe it's more of a lighthearted one
flood is wrong but but you got but you
have the comedy to connect you more to
the characters and
these are good characters but I felt
like you know when some of these big
dramatic scenes are happening I'm like
man I would have felt even more for some
of these characters if I did laugh with
them a little bit more if there were
more scenes like with the gadgets and
stuff like that problem I thought it was
nice I thought it was nice to see a
Marvel movie where the characters could
just be bad no no no but but humor is a
big part knowledge humor big part of
being badass but humor is also a big
part of making a connection and I still
connect it with these people and that
these characters are all very distinct
and I enjoy them fine but at the same
time I'm thinking like man I feel like I
could have been watching the climax of
this and thinking like this is huge this
is like Return of the King you know kind
of movie I didn't have the budget what
no but I will say one if it won't even
there's no the setup is there and I feel
like we could have had that as either a
this was a sequel or be there is a
little bit more comedy connecting us to
the characters a bit high if you want my
maybe my one gripe is I do feel not that
this is a lesser Marvel movie with the
budget but it's just like I felt like
the budget couldn't compete with what
they were trying to put on cuz I get
they feel like they literally you're
doing the Lord of the Rings thing we're
like the Riders of Rohan come into the
middle of the battles they bi it never
felt like it never quite kadai was very
CGI very like I never quite connected
and it felt all kind of a little more
low-budget compared to probably know why
we've got infinity yeah you know they're
they're saving their money I'm saying
for okay the climax of this movie so I
think Black Panther I see these worlds I
see this stuff I think like the climax
is gonna be you know in a field with a
big battle they got that and our two
main heroes on top of a giant building
of that Sun setting and they're fighting
it's in this underground little oh I
like the train station which okay it's
cool but I'm just thinking like man for
what's building up with this villain and
everything I mean like this could have
been just this grand epic bout where the
visuals match you know like the drama
that's going on between these two
but then
can't we get stuff like the waterfall
fight where that was kind of going on
yeah that would have been repetitive I
thought the underground cave was super
cool I thought and it won't give it away
but how they end the battle and top it
there's a big cinematic well framed
shots to close it out that's one thing I
was thinking like well like when they be
fighting their what why couldn't that be
and it's like if you don't tell me I
tell you but it would spoil it but yet
no there isn't just the logical reason
just from the filmmaking perspective of
why it wouldn't work in the sulky I know
you're talking about yang catism and
everything you're gonna have that going
through no not only that but just they
had to go to that location for a
specific reason you know I know but
because that was an important plot point
for the villains character and his
emotional journey and we get to say
things like emotional journey in a
Marvel movie I don't think you're giving
some of the Marvel movies enough credit
I mean it's like I granted I see a ton
of them and they do get a little too
later I think it's too later Captain
America's credit and I give of all
things guardians of the galaxy to credit
yeah there's a whole like swath of them
though where I'm just like know that
yeah this is what's the emotional
journey in in Iron Man 2 in Thor - well
you pick the two worst Marvel movies but
no I did yeah ant-man or homecoming as I
know what you're talking yeah I even
source like Thor 3 maybe but there were
so many jokes and I didn't mind it there
because I just had given up on Thor but
the first Thor movie had some of it but
then he's wandering around the desert
that's ya know it's it's it's a tricky
thing because these Marvel movies are
coming out so much and they are so good
they're so consistently good even when
they're quote unquote bad they're not
really that bad an Iron Man 2 is not
that bad compared to other bad
comic-book movies it's really not it is
um but it's one of those things where
it's like at the same time you do catch
on these things a little bit more at
least for me I do become a little bit
more critical because they become harder
to top and her
and make these things unique but at the
same time this one does still seem to be
kind of separate it's more kind of the
callbacks to those Marvel traditions
that set it back and then leaving out
some of the crucial ones like having
more back to a Black Panther in there
you know and having some of the action
be a little bit more I know this is the
kind of cool stuff you can do it was a
strangely character-driven movie which I
I wasn't sure that I was actually
expecting that I thought wasn't be like
another movie will be bad as it is and
then it was all that but I'm like oh wow
like this was strangely more
character-driven and really wasn't about
just a guy in the suit like punching a
bunch of people he actually has to deal
with shit again even okay with Iron Man
that's not just a dude punching people
he is funny but he's deeply flawed he's
deeply dramatic and some of the most
powerful dramatic scenes in the Marvel
movies are centered around him and same
thing with Captain America and okay
that's fine yet we'll get to it you know
but I mean whatever man was funny has no
guardians of the galaxy and stuff like
that it's like again I think these are
chemicals and the comedy does play a
part it doesn't always need Iron Man was
the story about how a drunken lecher
basically realized that his company was
selling shit to people so he was going
to build an iron suit to basically use
the same weapons that his company was
making to blast them out of himself it
wasn't really bad Eddie
see I think that's what you just said
there it's like holy shit is basically
just that dime I did especially when the
cave went with the dude and stuff like
that especially in civil war when he has
to confront you know not only what he's
become you know but what he is becoming
and what he has to stop and what's good
again you pick the one like the Civil
War is the one that checked all this out
the window like did pretty much like
what Black Panthers doing where it's
like oh we can do things different but
Civil War still had the same issue where
it's just like hey can we throw about a
hundred and one jokes in the middle of
this fight sure and it was fun I'm not
saying that I don't need like I enjoyed
the hell out of that but it's really
refreshing to finally have a Marvel
movie
that is not treating me like I'm
literally 10 years old
mmm no this this is pretty all like I'm
trying to think this probably the least
kid-friendly Awan I can it's not
kid-friendly at all
and not because like there's not a whole
bunch of swearing or gory again maybe
what your soldiers are close its kind of
watch this and be like what like you
know yeah I don't know how many choices
is gonna sell this is this is an older
if it's for anybody it's for older kids
like um and it's nice to be talked to
like I'm an adult from a Marvel movie
like the the Nolan Batman films didn't
generally know and it doesn't get
anywhere near there it doesn't get to no
no it's not Nolan lamb a level but it's
but it's definitely more I feel closer
to that wheelhouse
than the other Marvel movies mmm like I
just feel like it was just I don't know
it was refreshing me that i sat through
a Marvel movie I was like oh you weren't
talking to me like I'm literally five
years old and I'm only here to buy like
your Happy Meal toys and it doesn't feel
like a matrix or you know serve a Dark
Knight Rises movie where it's just
constantly have you thought about this
have you thought about you you don't
feel the wagging finger too much like
you feel like okay these are characters
just experiencing what they're
experiencing and they're not talking to
you what they're trying to say they're
just going through what they're going I
thought the Dark Knight was fine but in
the case of the matrix is because this
is a character-driven movie the matrix
was doing by long strings of dialogue
and like yeah we're just going to spout
philosophical shit like there was no
sense of character in the matrix yeah
pal was like I don't know what was what
whoa
what was this character like oh I'm the
one what you learn well I'm the one yeah
but what you learn become the one on the
one okay so people are coming out the
Woodward's by the way icons we were
always like thank you for saying the
matrix is stupid I'm like but it's
ironic because I thought this chase as
much as I hate the second Matrix movie
this chase in this film it's probably
the best chase I've seen since that
movie like that highway chase in the
second Matrix me
and this one I'm just like wow this
reminded me of that weird like that the
music the choreography of it especially
exists everything I was just like jam
and I was like this is awesome
you know what I'll say this too I said
two things I loved element and a third
the music I loved and the songs are just
a lot of ass arms going on I loved it
yeah and it one thing I missed by the
way and again I don't think it's giving
away too much but during that car chase
like okay so circus has got this badass
arm and he shoots this car and either
you see this why you the general cheesy
hot sound let's stick on this metal
thing it does the slim facial and then
you see the other one like a cartoon she
only has the wheel and the seat and she
goes like oh man well that was funny did
they have she got out like that that's a
lot as a side note this movie has black
Valkyries and they're amazing mmm
yielding their spears flying through
their that tongue to them twice now in
about the span of a year they've seen to
the you know I seen it's happened twice
I don't really see that often and it's
like yeah just like never always seen
that of film maybe exist I haven't seen
it uh and that's an army of women
roaring going into battle I just said
like it was badass
you know this I also kind of had no it
was this and was Justice League like
there's this big army of women coming in
here ah ha ha ha like that and it just
sort of threw me off like what is that
I'm like oh that's an army woman roaring
I've never heard that in you think like
something just like that with you know
be somewhere but I'm like I never had
you heard that and this was the second
one where I heard that I'm just like oh
that's cool
it's just something I don't even think
of like until you hear it I'm like oh
like I'm sure it's in another movie
somewhere by just I never heard it
before and yeah I like the fact that
they that the costumes are very distinct
very colorful all
different I like the way they gave the
tribes sort of explain it it's very epic
odda Africa like it's but but they're
they're grabbing different ideas from
different African cultures in creating
their own sort of comic book
interpretation there's only one that we
were seeing was kind of just dragged
it's just this one dude
okay the closer that does did the whole
discs in their mouths
then I did mine cuz there's a few enough
there but there's one guy there's one
dude whatever reason they dressed him
like the Riddler
yeah dude bright neon green and like no
no the others have like bright colors to
me you know these beautiful designs the
stuff like that but this dude has like
if it was you had to pick one or the
other either have to do the disc and
then a dressing like everyone else or
you have to do the suit within no disc
but the two combined every time you
showed up
it took me out I just don't like it man
does that not match anything else
nobody else is wearing a suit did he
help fund the movie is he a family
member because I just feel like the
movies desperate to be like look at this
guy yeah look at him and then say the
disc I think was bright green - but this
is
he's just glowing Nickelodeon slide yeah
green colored like Rover well yeah your
power green no okay any of the thing
like I said and there's probably it's
beautiful story but I'm being ignorant
and stuff like that you know don't get
me wrong but it's like there's a huge
scene happening where this guy is always
in the background while this incredibly
important students from Adam years ago
all the arrows point to this dude yeah I
use immediately like that dude oh middle
of a challenge is getting his asking
this big drag murders
yeah in the neon green and I'm like that
cut did that just like my eyes are just
me like that dude
yeah the African Riddler that's all like
I just yeah seeing the Riddler for so
and I've seen that before I've seen that
kind of suit before I've seen that that
disc before instead there's other people
I have that disc it's the combination of
the two Chuck how compared to everybody
else you drew your eye too much and he's
supposed to be in there a number of
discs there are a number of discs in the
film and I was a colored people yeah and
I was fine with that like everything
they did that was fine he was just that
one guy in particular also fucking count
wore a suit tune I don't marry anyone
else wearing like a suit they're so like
these three very distinct things they're
just a melee gonna draw your eye every
time he says it's an epic like so all
this stuff I talk on and on about they
are kind of nitpicks um like I said this
is still I'm not gonna say it's a
perfect movie but it's for a Marvel
movie its way up there mmm like I like
this is like probably my top 5 yeah
usually it's probably um it's easily the
most dramatic it's probably the most
adult like I said a soldier in civil war
are pretty adult but they do get into
the goofy stuff you know war is a health
and stuff but winter I'll give you I'll
give you winter soldiers Civil War is a
is a fun that's a great movie it's I
don't go to that one I'm like well this
is adult like it's if you cut out that
Airport battle think of everything else
in that movie yes if you cut out the
centerpiece of the movie the thing that
they just totally were just like this is
it we throw everybody together in one
battle and they crack jokes for 20
minutes like yes maybe yes but in a
two-hour movie yeah but that's literally
the centerpiece of the movie I think
it's like literally in the center of the
film like at the halfway point and
there's a lot of adult stuff in that
movie still no I think this is easily
the most adult it probably is
and they don't read they don't wreck it
with jokes like it's they almost every
it seemed like I don't need jokes I need
I need a little bit more levity for
somebody cuz there are long periods
where people are talking and they're
staring out and they're thinking about
stuff and things like that and they're
good and like real movies
no no good and they're needed but
sometimes I need to just like you know
have a little chuckle and there are a
few chuckles like I said with her making
the gadgets and stuff like that I mean
even she the sisters play that hard it
just it didn't it didn't feel like you
needed to just talk down to me or play
KP the hallways no I I wanted to adjust
the criticism of Marwan okay okay
I like Marvel me okay okay that the dude
of force would occur in this movie the
minute you see him you know what's gonna
happen to them and I was thinking to
myself you know if this guy did
something a little more different a
little more unique you know my mind does
go to humor I'm not gonna lie but you
know just something a little bit more
different unique I would have felt you
know holy shit
you know when the thing you know that's
gonna happen happens so it's one of
those things where it's like if not
humor or or levity it's just something
to get a little bit more connection
beyond kind of seeing what obvious trope
this is what obvious part is gonna
happen you know to some of these care
like I said even for the stuff with like
the pile and stuff like that FBI
interview you used to be a pilot and you
know my hey my king my love and stuff
it's like if there's a little bit more
of a connection with them I would forget
those I keep mentioning the pilot thing
I even noticed that line okay and they
mentioned it at the end and I figured
well they must have mentioned it
somewhere earlier in the movie babies
but I I mean stuff like that you know
you know when I was too busy wondering
Andy Serkis be completely bad know with
the two generals apparently having like
a romantic connection and stuff like
that if they talked a little bit or just
fooling around you know are just like
neighs enjoy or something like to show
they're a couple a little bit more like
things like that like that kind of
levity would have made later scenes even
heavier so it Amman two-and-a-half-hour
movie probably even longer sure you know
like I said but that doesn't mean it's
not still a you know a little bit of an
issue but it's it's still a little bit I
didn't have an issue I okay I mean it's
like Oh
I mean people acting like this is some
okay no I guess I I guess I'm gonna get
stuck here actually watching people like
act you know I feel like I'll feel like
I'll probably be the OP person out on
that because everyone seems to be it was
ailing 97 percent or something like that
and the people I like yeah oh those
pretty excited paid off
so clearly yeah including well Beauty
and the Beast I might believe that but
but no I it's one of those things where
it's like everyone seems to be an
agreement you know with you that this is
like you know we did do one of the best
Marvel movies and stuff like that um for
me it it is very very good I hadn't just
been something like Ant Man or any of
the the mid-level Marvel movies but just
had an all happen to have an all-black
cast I would probably it's good it's the
fact that it happens to be a really good
movie on top of all the other historical
precedents at setting that's you know
makes it work for me
it's one of those things where it's it's
very clearly trying to be a really big
movie I want it to be a really big movie
and what I got was a really good movie
you know it's one of those things I kind
of wanted it to be great I thought the
only my only complaint is I don't think
the budget was able to match what their
vision
no um you know the storyboards for this
were gorgeous and they managed to cram a
lot of it in there but it was just like
yeah this looked better in your skirt
story honestly the budget went to what
mattered the most and said apart the
most and that is the environments
you know these worlds the costumes and
stuff and it might be event is moral or
fucking cats yeah there was not there's
not a waste of the actor in this like
everybody I felt just really sold it
yeah again I can't think of anything bad
in the movie at all like said the
closest has made the effects which again
I understand and I kind of excuse
because I'm enjoying the rest of it you
know and even then it's just kind of the
action effects like everything else
- because I was talking about this I
watch this anime called little witch
academia and something I'd realized when
I got to the end of it was that it was a
show about girls probably a knit girls
that I was some Kickstarter anime
project but and I realized that it was
girls solving the problems and the
villains were girls basically everything
was girls I was like yeah that's really
into it and like the same thing here
it's just like black people starring in
it about black people with the villain
like we can talk about Andy Serkis but
he's really the side banana Ville and
like with a black villain like it really
was like all about them and I'm like
that it's just kind of refreshing to see
like and they made a really good movie
out of it like well yeah I mean this
could have been like fantastic for some
piece of shit like you know but it's
well they both had Michael B Jordan when
the movie starts don't worry you will be
able to follow it because when the movie
began and they just they throw a lot at
you really fast I'm just like oh no I'm
gonna be lost I'm gonna they they slow
it down you catch out they explain stuff
more and everything cuz I said the
backstory mixed with then the other
hairs another thing they did that I
really enjoyed about this you don't need
to see the other Marvel movies to get
most of this know if not all of it in
fact I think you could go in completely
blind and pretty much with what they
give you in kind of flashbacks put
together what happened in Civil War and
the other things that led up to this
film yeah and even like the girls are
dying they explained yeah you could tell
that they're like no we really want
everybody to see this movie you don't
have to be just a Marvel comic book fan
and you don't have to have the
encyclopedic knowledge like okay yeah I
think that's one of the reasons that I
don't have an encyclopedic knowledge of
why can't their anyway so no I know we
should make that clear - I have never
read the comic I have no idea what Black
Panther is about at all so I'm not
compared if all the people reading is
like okay like I don't have no clue I am
I'm assuming its faithful cuz a lot the
other Marvel properties are pretty
faithful you know but except Iron Man 3
yeah I have no idea but yeah it's Bob
making a subject you're a huge fan of a
comic I had no idea this policy or not
but yeah it's it's a good movie it's
probably yeah probably the most adult
that Marvel's ever done it is different
it's not quite as much superhero II like
it is in there but like I said I I don't
know how many toys is gonna sell I do
not think this is a toy you know it but
at the same thing it's like up like they
make Disney movies to sell toys and
stuff like that up probably did not sell
that made toys but it was a really great
phenomenal movie it's weird because I
think like kids could see this easily
but I feel like you know I don't feel
like it's targeting kids like it's very
much like if kids want to go see it and
enjoy it and there's lots to feel more
adult yeah and there's a lot of there's
a lot of great messages to take out of
it so I think a kid could see easily and
then like you know it's good for them I
just don't think it's just not a bad
thing so like others are like it's
definitely like not like going well
we're here just for the five year olds
it would be a challenging film for kids
but I think in a good way um you know
it's not something I say take all your
kids to see that's I think they have to
kind of want to see it this has to be a
movie they want to sit down and be like
I want to try and follow this and
understand this and get what's happened
what's very inspiring it's like go
hiking for adults when he said like
stand up you are king I was like yeah
it's like well as a kid I mare like a
few good men was on and I was just like
I I know this is an adult movie and I
probably be able to follow that but I
want to try I really want to try I want
to be an adult and figure this stuff out
everything and I when you started
ranting in that Jack Nicholson voice
about how you were gonna piss down my
dad's I realize perhaps maybe
but but I think every kid kind of gets
to that point with movies though and I
feel like like this is not a bad movie
to show kid it's like I kind of want to
be challenged I think this is like a
good introduction to that kind of stuff
yeah there's nothing there's not Batman
Returns okay yeah which by the way
Batman Returns is the greatest kids film
of all
[Applause]
yeah I know is there anything else like
do we want to go into spoilers or
there's nothing much to spoil and I just
figured out what happens hey babe my
favorite is they had this thing at the
beginning like don't leave it's a Marvel
movie there's gonna be something listen
mister oh I'm gonna have to get the food
and then they they like mentioned this
as in I am like like I'm like okay buddy
so we waited it was bullshit yeah okay
that's the one thing that disappointed
okay it was the final James that's dumb
a bad job but at the beginning they put
that ad back up everybody
okay I am NOT I've seen maybe the past
like three Marvel movies I've seen I see
maybe three people walk out everybody
else date everybody knows the drill I
never seem to like a giant herd of
people leave our been living like this
past three four years the first scene
they do after what used to be the
opening credits now they're always at
the end with the colorful credits with
all the imagery and you know the first
one the AB in between the credits was
good cuz it wrapped up a couple things
I'm like oh that's that's nice oh but
then staying through all the rolling
credits for that scene at the end I'm
like fucking kidding me after you told
me like no you need to stay this is
important yeah like it's something like
[Laughter]
I'm mrs. spoil it for you just here
spoiler corner so it's they're like are
you then it's like three little African
kids like looking directly at the camera
I'm like okay and it's was it
sister yes yes they're good because
she's the tech Queen and she's like yeah
slash back here um and she's like are
you still playing with that that white
guy like and then like freakin Bucky
walks out and she's like how are you
sergeant Barnes and and he's just like
my name's Bucky and I just laughed I'm
just like really it's like a melon yeah
I know I was like I just want to say
nobody will take you seriously if we
call you Bucky taking the guys the
realist is more serious than you quite
self yeah if they have that the
beginning stage Allah how about Wakanda
opening a swarm a shop you know is I'm
not gonna be like Thor's something like
that stepping like how that happened you
know or spider might say it's like oh
it's the guy we already knew was there
but he's a white guy yet maybe that's it
he's awake
yeah nothing so yeah that's about it go
see it it's a formal condom
yeah it's actually that always makes you
laugh cuz we have a book on de Illinois
and it's like 90%
[Laughter]
well it's spelled differently man
okay so Oh kanda button so that's about
it go see for yourself and don'ts what
do you think no other thing to say
you were dismissed call me Bucky now
you